hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts the strep tag system for
efficient protein purification of X V
supernatant presented by Dennis Carr
house scientists I be a life sciences
I'm Alexis crowds of labyrinth and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
birds and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information about
our sponsor please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license I'm for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem please join me in
welcoming Dennis Carter house I will now
turn the presentation over to him so
thank you very much and welcome from my
side to all of the audience today I
would like to introduce you to the
traffic system and how you can use it
for efficient protein purification from
XP supernatant
so a lot of sciences we have many
applications and experiments where we
need only protein in a milligram range
but we need it very quickly one example
is the drug discovery process
pharmaceutical companies where often
several hundreds of possible candidates
are expressed screen simultaneously and
in this phase of R&D the pharmaceutical
companies try to reduce the time as much
as possible because it's earlier you
find a leading candidate the audio you
can go on with your clinical trials and
finally the earlier you on the market
with a product that brings in some money
another vacation example where
milligrams of protein are sufficient are
taught psychological studies or binding
and kinetic studies and furthermore for
first animal studies usually a few
milligrams of protein are sufficient the
basic research you're often dealing with
many different projects but again there
you often need only protein in a
milligram range but you need it very
quickly because you don't want to waste
much time in the production of your
protein you want to start with your
experiment as quick as possible
another experiment is crystallography
where you usually are fine with a few
milligrams of protein or the SI
development and finally protein
interaction studies so when you rely on
a mammalian expression system transient
expression is the best way how you can
produce protein in a milligram up to
gram range for some proteins in a very
short time because you don't have to
screen or to select data cell lines you
can reduce the time for the production
and usually you get your protein within
days so in transient expression you
benefit from a very high initial
expression during the first days after
transaction before the expression drops
and that makes transient expression a
perfect choice for iceberg good
applications like drug screening and we
already heard some nice presentations
today where such applications were
outlined so the X P expression system
from the sam'l is a mammalian expression
system that is very well suited for this
transient expressions there are two
systems available on the market the XP
to 93 system and the XP Choa system and
those systems comes with chemical
defined meteor that allow the cells to
grow up to very high densities and
perfectly match transaction Regenesis
and answers
and feeding solutions so due to the high
cell density and the achieved high
protein titer it's possible to reduce
the scale for production and therefore
is the food print in your incubators and
it allows you to simultaneously scream
more drag candidates or process more
proteins in parallel and that's why is
this system very often used in
pharmaceutical companies for their rnd
and drug discovery applications however
expression of your protein is only one
side of the coin and the other one is
purification and every process is
limited by its bottlenecks so in order
to have a benefit of such high or
protein expressions and the ability to
screen many different proteins in
parallel you would need a beautification
strategy that is capable of purifying so
many different proteins simultaneously
the best way to do this is the use of
tax systems because tax can be fused to
any kind of protein and this allows you
to purify many different proteins with
the same purification strategy and the
same materials which will save you a lot
of time during the upstream downstream
process not surprising there is many
different tax systems on the market and
here are just a few examples of the most
prominent ones
one group of tags are so-called at the
top tags like the flag tag or even
lipstick these pegs to rely on an
antigen antibody binding and therefore
they are often eluded at low pH values
which can affect the properties of your
protein in addition the resins usually
have comparable no binding capacity and
are quite expensive this makes
purification especially of larger
amounts of protein expanses if you use
this tag systems another group of tags
are large text like the maltose binding
protein or the GST tag or shredder begin
tag this tag and increases solubility
of your protein of interest or its
expression but on the other side the
text can also influence the properties
of your protein of interest leading to a
different behavior in your further
experiments and that's something of
course you would like to avoid in
addition due to the high side
they are highly antigenic and if you
want to go in with your protein into
some first animal studies you usually
have a clip of this text before you can
go on with your experiments so the most
widespread check system on the market of
the hit text system because the system
is cheap and the tag is small so in many
applications it's not necessary to
cleave the tag however even this very
widespread system has many disadvantages
first of all and we've already hit it in
the talk of John the purification of
mammalian or sometimes even insect cells
can be quite challenging because
mammalian cells have more host cell
proteins with history and religious that
can be cool purified and chemically kind
media that allow the growth of high cell
density often have interfering
substances that interfere with the his
take purification in addition customers
are often facing incomes with impurities
which make it necessary to do a second
purification step in order to get pure
protein purity that is sufficient for
your experiments furthermore the tech
system often needs a kind of
optimization for example the
optimization of the imidazole
concentration in the sample or the wash
buffer in order to get a good compromise
between purity of your protein and
protein yield and finally the binding
affinity of the system is not high
enough to really efficiently use it in
immobilization experiments like spr
studies because you can see a remarkable
dissociation of the tag itself and that
complicates the data analysis
so in this conference we heard a lot of
the XP system so this experiment might
be very interesting because here we see
what happens is you load XP chose
supernatant without any further
treatment on a common nickel nta column
in this experiment we spiked twenty
milliliters of XP chose supernatant with
them and share refused to in his tank
and purify this twenty milliliters over
1mill it is our nickel nta column and as
you can see during the loading procedure
the protein starts to leak from the
column indicated by the white area and
the upper part of the column so it seems
that there are some substances in the
media that interview with the his tech
binding and obviously this is not the
most efficient way to purify a protein
from the supernatant so with all these
robocalls there for mention tact this
writes the question is there is an
attractive alternative technology that
can be used and for this we developed
the tracking strap tech system many
years ago and let's have a relook how
the system works the system depends on
two components the first component is
the threat tag peptide which is an eight
amino acids long peptide that can be
fused or to your protein of interest the
second component is strapped up team
which is a re-engineered strep RVD
that has an increased binding affinity
to the stretcher compared to
streptavidin
and what I'm you can use this Texas and
a lot of purify your proteins you use
your supernatant for example for
mammalian cell supernatant or
materialises whatever
and apply two chromatography
purification column like an a PLC column
or a gravity flow column and the protein
of interest will be found via the strep
techtube peptide which is bound to the
biotin binding pocket of the strep
turkey then you can walk away the
impurities under physiological
conditions and then you can elude your
protein by just adding this tile biotin
to your wash buffer this is very
beneficial because this is a very mild
illusion and you don't have to change
the buffer conditions to low pH values
or to high salt concentrations and that
means that proteins that maybe are
unspecific be bound to your matrix will
not be coded with your protein because
you don't change the buffer conditions
after illusion you can regenerate the
column by adding vitamin H which turns
the columns color red and then you watch
the way the hav a and you can go for a
new purification round so the advantages
of the system are high protein purity
czar for up to more than 95 percent due
to users to specific purification steps
of specific binding and the specific
illusion furthermore you have a great
flexibility regarding your buffer
composition here the system is
compatible with high salt concentrations
detergents metal iron chelation and
reducing agents which means you can
adjust the buffer to your protein of
interest but of course it's also very
effective to purify proteins on a
physiological conditions the resins is
reusable and the tact is very small so
it's usually not necessary to cleave of
the tag
however this system has also one
drawback and this is a relatively low
binding affinity in a micro molar range
so the system works very well for
bacteria lies it but when it comes to
know concentrate
protein samples which we are often
facing when we do mammalian expressions
then this binding affinity can be too
low for an efficient purification so
let's reason why we further developed
the system by the development of strap
techniques T and the twin strap check
the twin strep tag is taxed at converse
of twos to attract two peptides that are
linked together and due to this a linker
it's possible to target to biotin
binding pocket of the stretcher team
instead of only one creating an acidity
effect that increases the binding
affinity of the system the second
improvement was the development of
stress 1580 and you can see the
structure on the right side by mutation
of strata team and 315 et has a much
higher binding affinity for the strap
tag and therefore force was trafficked
for the transcript tag compared to the
stretcher team so together the strategy
and the strategy may exceed will have a
binding affinity in the non memorial
range so it's comparable to the his tech
system but with the twin strips it
prints traffic system and thus retro
Phoenix Eve you will get a binding
affinity in a Pico molecular range and
this is the highest binding affinity
available among all affinity
purification systems that are available
on the market so when we look to the
purification cycle of the stretch
thirteen exceed this is quite comparable
to the stretch 13 purification cycle
again you immobilize your protein of
interest via the strap tech or the twins
birthday instead 15 exceed and after you
load your sample on a chromatography
column you wash away the impurities and
then again you have those mild solution
by adding biotin instead of the style
biotin because the binding affinity for
biotin and death I will attend of
structure cleaning T is reduced compared
to strapped active and therefore we need
to use biotin which will block stress 15
Cullens irreversibly stripper community
condoms can be regenerated after the
biotin balances the biotin binding
pocket of struck our team exceed by just
adding NaOH and then you can use the
resin for a new pre-education round
so now let's have a look to some
benefits of the system
in this experiment we compared the
purification of strep 15 high capacity
and so 1560 high capacity the high
capacity materials have a three-fold
higher binding capacity compared to the
non high capacity material and for this
experiment we spiked what we dozen
spiked we use M sherry lies aids from
ecoli with the twins protect and
purifies the license on the two columns
and in the sdhd you can see the load in
lane 1 the wash fraction in lane 2 and
the illusion fraction in 93 and if you
will see the illusion fraction you can
see that those systems generated high
purity of nearly 100% the lower band is
the fragment of them sherry so it's not
an unspecific contamination however if
you look to the wash traction of strata
team you can see that a protein of
interest was already washed from the
column during the wash that due to the
lower affinity instead of when you
stretch 13 X T you can see that there
are no bands of the wash spectrums in
the last wash direction and that shows
you that proteins that is bound to the
separate exe column will not be released
pre or to illusion this is a great
benefit over other tax systems like
logistic system because it allows you to
wash with large watch volumes to even
get rid of a high containment
concentrated contaminant without losing
protein during the water procedure the
binding affinity of structure Kenickie
also increases the dynamic binding
capacity compared to strep 15 and if you
look to the right side you can see the
comparison of dynamic binding capacities
for mpre
measured on stretch 13 instructor PhD
high capacity and you can see by the use
of 15 X T we can increase the binding
see close to two full times compared to
straight 15 given to the fact that those
replicas mixing materials are cheaper
than the strategy materials it's
possible to reduce a cost for a
purification by more than 50% if you use
retro Phoenix tea instead of strapped up
team so I've already mentioned that the
system is quite compatible with
different detergents and these data here
were provided by Q biotech as I purified
GSP twins to attract refuse proteins in
the presence of 2% of different
detergents and as you can see in the SDS
page here none of the test the
detergents had any negative impact on
the protein purity which was nearly 100%
compared to the non detergent containing
control furthermore none of the tester
detergents had any negative impact on
protein you as you can see on the right
side and I think that's the most rate
that the system is quite compatible with
many detergents and makes it a very good
system for the pure occasional membrane
proteins in this experiment we compared
the purification of his tack protein on
nickel ante column and circuit enix t
purifications using the same proteins
fused to a twin strep tag so we use M
sherry and get the edge Liza and apply
them on a nickel nta column and then
purify them according to the
manufacturers protocol and as you can
see in the illusion fraction of M sherry
there are lots of contaminating bands
still present in the aleutian fraction
and obviously here at second
purification step would be necessary in
order to achieve a good protein purity
the gap th purification looks better
especially because the gal th is highly
concentrated but again especially in the
upper part you can see many
contaminating proteins in contrast if
you use to replicate ET you can see that
we achieve nearly 1
percent pure protein for the emissary
purification and on the right side you
can see the Western blots that detect
both bands proving what I said that the
lower band is just a fragment of sherry
also tacked and therefore this special
case be kind of reduces con or this
fragment and even if you look to the gap
th which was not so bad in the history
of you refuse you can see that the
purity is much higher in the strata
Kenickie system compared to the his tech
system and all these experiments here
were done under physiological conditions
so I've mentioned their high binding
affinity also strategy McGee system and
these data are provided by the company
dynamic biosensors and dynamic
biosensors developed which sense
technologies that can be used for
kinetic statics like SPR but can be used
for many different other applications
those are very powerful technology and
they already release a twin straight leg
or static cat circuit that allows you to
capture strength track proteins on a
strep track Teaneck t chip and they
compared the binding affinity of GPUs to
a 10-step track and refused to a spread
tag in their system so if you look to
the left graph you can see that those
system has a very fast Association rate
but when you look to the dissociation on
the right side you can see a remarkable
dissociation for the strep tech protein
which has a comparable binding affinity
like the his tag so if you would use a
hist a capturing it you will actually
see such a dissociation in contrast if
you look to the twin strep tech
immobilized protein you can see a very
stable signal over a long time and this
demonstrates this technology is
perfectly suited for protein interaction
studies even if your binding affinity
between the two investigated protein
like antigens and antibodies is very
high and if you compare the binding
affinities you can see that the
strategies logistic on alone nano more
your range and that the twin strep Texas
chapter Phoenix T system is in a no
people more your range so um let's get
back to and thoughts to the initial
start of the presentation when we see
the problems you can have purifying
istic proteins from XP supernatant and
the question if there is a attractive
alternative and when I was on a
conference I talked to Henry choose a
product manager for the AC system and we
discussed the topic about the problems
with his de purification and he was
wondering if I was trapped X system
might be would face the same problems or
if it would be beneficial for the
purification of proteins from X T
supernatants so we started a cooperation
and I like to thank tango for this
cooperation and providing supernatant
for us and we thought it with XP to 93
supernatants let me say some words to
the experiment itself all experiments
were conducted if not mentioned
otherwise to microliters that technique
to gravity flow columns so the resin
volume was very small and as we are not
able to adjust the flow speed and
gravity flow mode the contact times were
very short round about only 20 seconds
usually for SPLC applications we cannot
recommend two minutes however we have
seen that the XP system is often used
for high throughput applications where
only very small expression volumes are
used and therefore you would need a
small columns and we thought that this
is a realistic application and scenario
for XP supernatants
all proteins that we spike to the
supernatant were twins protect proteins
okay so the first question that was very
interesting for us what is the biotin in
the equatorial medium would interfere
with our protein purification nearly all
chemical defined media for mammalian
cells contain biotin and you remember
biotin is a substance that we use for
illusion of our protein so usually not a
very good case if you have the substance
that you use for illusion in your sample
however our illusion buffers have much
higher biotin concentrations than the
biotin concentration is in the 80 to 93
meteor and so we wanted to answer the
question do the concentrations of biotin
in the media interfere with the protein
purification for this experiment we used
the XP 293 supernatant the supernatant
were generated by transfecting XP 293
cells with an empty vector we also
included all the enhancing solutions and
when the viability dropped to 75 percent
we harvested the supernatant that we use
for spiking so here with vive M sherry
and the monoclonal antibody to the
supernatant and then with Blizzard the
supernatant one part of the supernatant
was directly loaded on our strategic C
gravity flow column and the other the
other part was treated with bio lock
solution and of our W bio loss solution
is the solutions that blocked free
biotin in media so the biotin cannot
bind anymore to strep tract enix t
however it would be an additional
preparation step that we would like to
avoid
so we purified the supernatant and
finally analyzed the years after
illusion and if you see
the last graphic you can see that the
additional dialogue and Papa W does not
change the binding capacity and that
proves that the presence of biotin in
the media does not interfere with our
twin strata extra protein icky binding
and that means that you can directly
load your supernatant on the column
which is a great advantage compared to
the his deck purification we have seen
at the beginning of the slide of the
presentation we also checked the
influence of the proteins purity on the
right side and you can see that the
additional bio log and Baja W does not
have any influence on the purity we were
able to achieve nearly 100% pure protein
in this single purification step in all
experiments however another question
that was interesting also was are there
any substances in ancestors or Hotel
proteins that may be interview with the
binding reducing binding capacity but
not completely in heathers as a protein
binding and to investigate this fact we
use pure xB 2 & 3 medium we supernatant
and supernatant where we added enhancer
solutions and spiked and sherry protein
to the supernatant purified all samples
and never saluted amount of protein and
as you can see in the graphics none of
the tested components add a negative
impact on the protein years that proves
that neither the experiment we host
their proteins nor and hands of
solutions or components of the axis 293
system to interfere with our 13 XT
purification
so once we figure out that the system is
not a problem for the purification of
septic proteins on 1580 we want to
further investigate the performance of
our circuit enix team with the XP - runs
free system so one question was how is
the maximum protein binding capacity on
column is influenced by the
concentration of our protein of interest
in the supernatant for this question we
spiked three proteins and sherry a
monoclonal antibody and secreted
alkaline phosphatase to HP 293
supernatant to a final concentration of
100 micrograms per milliliter or 200
micrograms per milliliter and purifies
the samples and again measured the
looted amount of protein you can see
that for the M sherry and the secreted
out line phosphatase the protein
concentration has no impact on the
protein huge but if you look to the
monoclonal antibody you can see that the
binding capacity was reduced as a
protein concentration was lowered this
is not very surprising me because we
adjust this is the supernatant - the
same mass concentrations of our protein
of interest but as the monoclonal
antibody will be twofold larger than the
secreted alkaline phosphatase and five
of larger than the M sherry that means
that an ammonia concentration that
drives the diffusion force is lower
compared to the other two proteins
furthermore the monoclonal antibody has
a larger size so the diffusion into the
pores especially to the inner part of
the core is slower and maybe you limited
for a protein for this protein side and
that means that the years for low
concentrated samples are reduced in
addition please keep in mind that we
have the only a contact time of 20
seconds which was really short for
purification process and if you have a
longer residence time than your water
that also achieve higher binding
capacities however if you look to the
protein use on the right side you can
see that the protein concentration of
the supernatant of our protein of
interest do not have an influence on the
protein purity again for all three
proteins we were able to achieve nearly
100% at least more than 90 percent pure
protein in a single purification step
without any adjustments of the
purification protocol is the same
protocol you use for materialises etc
Thor you don't have to optimize the
procedure so he will purify a protein
usually you don't want to overload your
column and use protein and therefore we
did this experiment where we loaded the
comes worth up to 75% of the maximum
binding capacity with data mined before
and again we spiked the supernatant with
our three proteins to the two
concentrations of 100 and 200 micrograms
per milliliters and compared the amount
of load of protein to the amount of
proteins that we looted from the Cubs on
the left side you can see that the
concentration of proteins in supernatant
had no in big influence on the recovery
for all proteins and we were able to
achieve very good recovery rates close
to 100% for Liam sherry protein and 80
to 90 percent for the monoclonal
antibody and secreted alkaline
phosphatase and not very surprising the
purity of the proteins were very high
again for all concentrations as you can
see in detail at this page here on the
right side
so I think these results showed is that
the strepsirhini
T twins tax system is very efficient in
the purification of proteins from XP to
93 supernatants finally we wanted to
make an experiment you could say under
real conditions because we have the leg
be 2 9 3 system here in house so we
transacted XP 2 9 3 cells with a vector
coding for secreted alkaline phosphatase
or the monoclonal antibody and
cultivated the cells until they reach
the viability of 75% and then we
harvested the supernatant which was only
30 milliliters and purified the
supernatant on a one milliliter striking
XT high-capacity gravity flow column we
use a high capacity column here because
we knew that secrete an alkaline
phosphotase is expressed very well and
we expected a huge amount of protein
even from the 30 milliliters and we
wanted to be sure that we get all the
protein so you can see when we
calculated the yield for one little
production we achieved 300 milligrams
per liter for the secreted alkaline
phosphatase and any six milligrams per
liter for the antibody it's worth to
mention that this was a rabbit antibody
and we've already heard in the
presentations of John that human
antibodies are higher expressed and 80
to 93 systems so this was a kind of
challenging monoclonal antibody and if
it's here on the right side you can see
again that another's real conditions we
were able to achieve very high protein
purity from the purification of the
samples so as you can imagine we were
quite happy with this result and
samovars too but then then will told us
ok maybe you know we should have a trial
the XP Cho system because this system is
much more challenging so the cell
densities are higher so we have more
wholesale protein
in the supernatant and we have a
different biotin concentration so we
wanted to see how we can work with our
system in this expression system the
experiment were conducted in the same
way like for the XP to 9-3 system we use
twin septic proteins again we use the
small column volumes of 200 microliters
and therefore the short residence time
and the supernatant were provided by
example it's worth to mention that the
supernatant already contain and
overexpressed monoclonal antibody that
was expressed in the last of terminal so
in this supernatant we have a kind of
artificial high concentrated
contamination that we usually would not
have an annex pto supernatant when we
purify to instruct tech proteins so
first of all again we checked if it's
necessary to add bio log solution or
buffer W to the xB to show supernatant
or if we can directly load our
supernatant that we spiked with some
shearing monoclonal antibody on the
column and again quite similar to the
result of where is the xB 293 system you
can see that the additional by 11 buffer
W doesn't did not change the protein
years so again also for the equity o
system the presence of biotin did not
interfere with the binding of our twins
cryptic protein on strap kapeniak steep
and if you look on the right side you
can see again the SS page --you'll of
the purification and if you look to the
allusions you can see that even for
higher host cell protein concentrations
we achieve very high purity zuv close to
100% in the xB Cho system however if you
have a closer look you can see in the
elusion fraction 2 residual bands that
correspond to the molecular weight of
the overexpressed antibody that is very
nicely seen in the load of the samples
so as I've already mentioned usually you
would not have such a high contamination
in your su
natan and obviously our standard
protocol with five wash volumes is not a
lot enough in order to get rid of such a
high artificial contamination in order
to prove this assumption we use your
supernatant where we buy secreted
alkaline phosphotase to liquid show
supernatant and in the ESP shield on the
in the middle you can see the chromatic
G of this purification you can see that
we have the two antibody bands in the
illusion fraction of the secreted
alkaline phosphotase illusion and we
wrote it the supernatant and this
illusion fraction on Western blot and
detected the lot with an anti-human
antibody conjugated to H R P and you can
see that the heavy chain of the antibody
was detected in the road and in the
illusion fraction which proved that this
is a contamination you usually would not
see in your twin subject purified
samples however we thought this would be
a great opportunity to see how we can
use our system to even deal with such
high concentrated contamination and you
remember that we have the possibility to
do this intensive wash procedures due to
our high binding affinity which is not
so easy with other tack systems so we
shoot a little bit with canon two birds
but we purified the three proteins that
secreted alkaline phosphatase and sherry
and the monoclonal antibody by applying
30 column volumes of wash buffer during
the wash procedure and if you look to
the illusion fractions now you can see
that we were able to remove the
contaminating bands off the overexpress
antibody and we think that this
experiment really shows that you can
even get rid of very high concentrated
count
nations and this is a great advantage of
this system compared to other system
because it gives users possibility to do
the tens of watch procedures for the
more you can imagine that you might be
have proteins that be on the column that
you have to wash away by adding some
detergents other by salt concentration
so it gives you also the possibility to
wash with different wash buffers without
getting a data to use your protein to
achieve high protease even for very
challenging purification tasks so back
to the experiments that we've already
conducted for the XP to nights research
them here for the you chose system again
we wanted to see how the protein
concentration affect the binding
capacity again we'd like the immature
supernatant was all three proteins two
final concentrations of 100 and 200
micrograms per milliliter purified them
on the 200 micrometer excuse colors and
never the amount of into protein and the
experiments are compared the results are
comparable to X 293 result you can see
that for them sherry and the secreted
alkaline phosphotase the concentration
of the protein has no influence on the
recovery but the monoclonal antibody
binding capacity was again reduced as
the concentration was lower obviously
duties the same effect that I've already
explained in the HP 293 system over at
this point of time we were wondering how
the binding capacity would increase if
we increase the residence time to two
minutes like you would use on an FP ltu
column or that you see if you use a
column with more with a lot of that
volume and for this we use the Gildan
aspects the pipetting devices that
allowed us to adjust the flow speed and
the residence time and you can see how
the binding capacity changes if you
increase the residence time or proteins
were or two achieved higher binding
capacities for all proteins
like five milligrams for the M sherry
and the secreted alkaline phosphatase
and the monoclonal antibody was 5 to 100
micrograms per minute assurances
experiment because obviously this was a
more challenging condition and you can
see that it's also possible to increase
the binding capacity for this low
concentrated model monoclonal antibody
and again on the right side you can see
that the protein purity was not affected
by the concentration the only real
contamination you can see is the over
expressed antibody because this is a
following experiment we haven't used the
30 column volumes of who watch volume to
save a little bit of time so again the
next experiment was to check how the
recovery is influenced by the protein
concentration the xp2 system and again
we see that the recovery was not
affected by the protein concentration in
the supernatant doesn't matter if we use
200 or 100 micrograms per milliliter of
our three proteins of the XPO
supernatant we achieve the recovery of
around about 90% for him sherry but you
can see that the recovery was lower here
below 80% for the monoclonal antibody
into secreted alkaline phosphatase and
again we were wondering how this would
change if we increase the residence time
so we increase the residence time again
and you can see that by increasing the
residence time we increase the recovery
for the monoclonal antibody to up to
100% and the secreted alkaline
phosphatase to close to 90% the
impairing recovery was not affected but
this is obviously due to the fact that
the recovery rate was already very high
was 90 percent and again you can see the
illusion fraction of this page filled
that for concentrations and all
purifications we get this nice high
protein purity
so when that you chose system here in
also we tell we're not able to express
our proteins in the system itself but we
use the chance to challenge the system a
little bit more by testing very low
concentrated of protein concentrations
in the XP Cho supernatant and in this
experiment we spiked the XP chose
supernatant were to a final
concentrations between 13 and 20
micrograms per milliliter with our three
proteins and then we loaded 50
milliliters of Exeter supernatant on
only 300 micro low litter back volume
containing Spector txt column and this
is a large volume of supernatant
compared to the resins volume remember
the purification of the his neck protein
where protein started to leak from the
column of already 20 milliliters on a
one-minute air columns so here we wanted
to see what happens if we apply large
volumes if you use the XP system for
manufacturing of large scale expressions
with a large system again we measure the
loaded amount of protein and the loaded
amount of eluted amount of protein and
you can see that even for this very
small concentrations we were able to
achieve around 100 percent recovery it's
worth missing that in this experiment we
use the Gans II a speck processing
device in order to achieve a residence
time of two minutes and if you see to
the right side you can see again that
the only present contamination is the
overexpressed antibody with only 7
volumes for column volumes for washing
the column and I think this demonstrates
that even for very low concentrated
sample and challenging XP shows
supernatant it's possible to achieve
high protein purity and recovery with
the twin stripped extra protein xt
system and due to the very easy protocol
i think this system is very perfect
addition to the XP system and together
the great technology and system in order
to do highest group of purification of
proteins
so that brings me up to the summary the
1718 Prince Turki system I think it's
really a superior purification system
because we have the exception of the
high binding affinity in the PG
molecular range and we have an
outstanding protein recovery and purity
we can achieve up to more than 98% pure
protein with short tag item I know a
certain cave of the skeptic 2 and 28 and
minor that he is a twin strap tag and we
know that for medications this tag does
not to be cleaved off even animal
studies were conducted with the twin
separate proteins and that was not a
problem you don't have to optimize the
protocol like or the his tech system
where you have to adjust the image or
salt concentration is the same protocol
for leg B 293 for the xB chose system
for bacterial lysis so it's a very easy
straightforward protocol we have a very
efficient purification from both HB 293
and there it shows supernatant we
achieve this high efficiencies without
any manipulation like dialyzer steps or
adding of any right reagents to the XP
supernatants we can directly load the
supernatant on our column and we have a
convenient immobilization of twin
separate proteins on surfaces like SPR
chips or the switch sense technology
this is very great because you can use
the tech not only for purification it's
the first time now that you can use is a
purification tech for SPR applications
even for very high binding affinity
kinetic studies otherwise you would you
have to biotin energy or protein in use
for example streptavidin chips but then
you have a addition biotin elation step
and i think this is really a great
advantage of the system and finally we
have a high compatibility with many
regions like high salt concentrations up
to five molar sodium chloride for
example of detergents metal ions she
lightest and reducing agents until to
come to the end of my presentation
sometimes a picture is worth a thousand
words you remember or nickel ante
a column from the beginning of the
presentation that you can see now on the
right side with the protein that leaks
from the current and of course that was
only half of issues because right next
to this column we place the shredder
quemic T high-capacity column where we
know the 20 milliliters of twins defect
I'm sharing to the column the
concentration protein mode was the same
than the nickel nta purification and you
can see that here no protein leaks from
the column we get a really nice sharp
binding off the protein in the upper
part of this column nothing this really
demonstrates how beneficial traffic enix
t twin traffic system is compared to the
his egg system and with this I thank you
for hearing the link to the torque and
open to some questions
Thank You Dennis for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button
once there's many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is why does biotin in
the medium not interfere with the
binding of the strep tag if biotin is
also used for Ellucian that's a good
question so what happens is the strep
tag and although the trans effect will
dissociate from time to time from the
biotin binding pocket but in case of the
twin subtags the second tag will be back
in place before the protein is eluted
from the column so if you use a biotin
in the dilution buffer what happens is
in the moment where the threat tag will
dissociate from the step 15 the biotin
will get into the BIOS in binding pocket
blocking it for the Strad pack and the
traffic will be eluted however this
binding is not irreversible which means
that also the biotin will be released
from to abide in binding pocket of
strapped actin so you need a large
excess of biotin in the illusion in
order to be sure that the next bios in
molecule will go into the binding pocket
before the threat tag can go back in
place however obviously the biasing
concentration in the XP media are much
lower concentrated and there is not
enough biotin present to get into the
free binding pocket before this traffic
gets back into the binding pocket and
you've seen the quick association rate
of the strep tech in the slides process
which sense technology and that's the
reason why the biasing concentration in
the X B 2 and X B 2 9 3 meter and
enough to prevent the twin strap back
from binding to the strap a Phoenix tea
is it possible to purify very large
proteins with the struck tact XT yes
that's definitely possible
we actually have customers who purifies
a 1.2 mega Dalton protein complex with
our resin of course you will lose
binding affinity because such large
complexes will not enter the tours of
the resin but yes it's definitely
possible to purify even very very large
proteins and protein complexes with the
system
okay Dennis our next question is what
are the con and cuff rates of the twin
strep tag to detect actin SP yes um the
key on rates are quite comparable
between the twin strep tag and respected
strepsirhini T so the K on rate will be
in a range of 5.5 multiplied with 10
high five and the key off rate will be 3
point 3 multiplied with 10 high minus 5
seconds so the K off rate is really
really slow and that leads to a final
Cody in the low Pico molecular range
which products can be used for the
purification of proteins do you offer
FPL CK trips yes there are several
product available so we have a great
flexibility how you would like to prove
by a protein you can use fut cartridges
we offer one milliliter and five minutes
are pre PEG cartridges but you can also
buy free slurry to pack your own
cartridge with amount of slurry you need
we are also having magnetic beads with
leukemic tea for very small batch
purification and we use it very
efficiently for highest lupus screenings
of small proteins of small samples yes
our next question is the strep tag
equally efficient on the N and
c-terminal of the protein yeah usually
it is actually this all right depends a
little bit on the protein itself and how
the structure of the protein is because
if one of the Tammy is folded in a way
that attack accessibility is very low
then of course on you cannot bind
protect very efficiently but then it's a
good choice to tell the other terminals
where the tech accessibility might be
better but if there is no protein
conformation that drives the attack to a
site where it's accessibility is not
very good then it doesn't matter if
you've used attack to the N or C
terminus at work post did you do test to
optimize the residence time and optimal
binding and supernatant volume dilution
effect
[Music]
I'm not quite sure if I understand the
question correctly so we optimized not
the resident time most of our
applications the two minutes residence
time is fine if we have lots of proteins
like the monoclonal antibody lots of
times might be beneficial but for most
proteins two minutes are sufficient in
order to get a good purification
regarding to the volume of the
supernatant and the volume of the resin
it depends only on the binding capacity
so if you have a very low concentrated
protein you can know too little of your
supernatant on the 1 million is your
column but if you have a very high
expression of course it would overload
your column our next question is did you
carry out same experiments with magnetic
stripe beads we haven't tested the
magnetic strategies with the xB chose
system yet all these experiments were
done with the agarose beads but that's a
very interesting question and I think
that gives us a very great idea what can
come next and I think we definitely
should look in this in the next
experiment because you can use magnetic
these very well in high schooler's
processes but I'm quite confident that
this will work too because the straps
are Teaneck t immobilizers of course the
same than on the agarose beads but yes
that's something we will have to look in
the next experiments
can I use this product in an e.coli
system yes the product works really
perfect in e.coli system actually the
first generation also stretch 13 skeptic
purification products were invented for
the using eco light and an e.coli
systems as you know you have usually
much higher contamination concentrations
because you have belies it but for the
most pure occasions we did here over the
last decades we get more than 90% pure
protein and once the purification
process even for e.coli on its system so
you can use it for e.coli for yeast
cells you can use it for insect cells
you can use it for mammalian expression
you can use it for membrane proteins or
sewer secreted proteins or proteins from
like that yeah actually you can do all
these things with the system
and if there are no more questions I
would like to once again thank Dennis
for his presentation I would also like
to thank Thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2019 please share that
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event also stay tuned for
our next presentation a comprehensive
workflow solution from gene synthesis
purified protein presented by dr.
Michaelis you won't want to miss it
that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye
you